We got this young man here. What's up,
buddy? You here?
Are you here? You got to unmute
yourself.
>> What happened?
>> Buddy, you have much noise in the
background.
>> Hey yo, what's up?
>> We can't have a talk if you have too
much noise in the background.
>> I was emailing you too much. You are not
seeing what
>> I was sending you emails.
all the time.
>> Yes. Yes, I know that. But I've been
busy, brother. But you got to make sure
you're in a room and there's not much
noise.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Okay. What's up? What do you want to
talk to me about?
>> Uh, I want to talk about the some verses
of the Bible that says Jesus of Nazareth
was a prophet.
>> You can quote those verses, but every
verse is going to backfire against you.
>> I think it was Luke 24:19.
Luke 24:19. So the same Luke that goes
on to say
that Jesus is also the one who died and
rose again from the dead. That Luke
>> he didn't saw Jesus. He didn't meet
Jesus.
>> You want to bet? You just quoted what
Luke wrote. So if he didn't see Jesus,
he meet Jesus. So why you quoting him to
tell you what people said about Jesus?
like he is telling about the people who
saw Jesus
>> and he's telling you that the people saw
Jesus alive because Jesus is now the one
they're speaking after he was
resurrected. So don't don't play games
with me. You just quoted Luke to trust
that
people said Jesus is a prophet. But this
Luke is telling you that this
conversation is taking place with Jesus
who now is alive risen from the dead.
And then he shows you that Jesus goes on
and say take it easy. Now while they
were telling these things, he himself
stood in their midst and said to them,
"Peace to you."
>> Okay. What is your answer to this that
the people
>> Can I answer you here?
>> Because the people are right. He's a
prophet and a priest and a king, but
he's a son of God who died for you. And
I'm going to show you how Luke is going
to embarrass. Let me read the chapter to
shows you that Muhammad is a son of
Satan. Hold on. Let's finish. You didn't
You read this and you read out of
context. Now while they're telling these
things, he himself stood in their midst
and said to them, "Peace to you." But
being startled and frightened, they were
thinking that they were seeing a spirit.
And he said to them,"Wh are you troubled
and why do you why do doubts arise in
your hearts? See my hands and my feet
that is I myself touch me and see? For a
spirit does not have flesh and bones as
you see that I have." And when he had
said this, he showed them his hands and
his feet. And while they still were not
believing because of their joy and were
still marveling, he said to them, "Have
you anything here to eat, they gave him
a piece of a broiled fish, and he took
it and ate before them. Now he said to
them, "These are my words, Jesus, which
I spoke to you while I was still with
you, that all things which are written
about me in the law of Moses and the
prophets and the psalms must be
fulfilled." Then he opened their minds
and understand the scriptures. And he
said to them, "Thus it is written that
the Christ would suffer and rise again
from the third day, from the dead on the
third day, and that repentance for
forgiveness of sins would be proclaimed
in his name and all the nations
beginning from Jerusalem. You are my
witness of these things. Behold, I'm
saying to you the promise of my father,"
so he's a son of God upon you. But you
are to stay in the city until you are
clothed with power from on high. Now
watch. And he led them out as far as
Bethany and lifted up his hands, he
blessed them. And it happened that while
he was blessing them, he parted from
them and was carried up to heaven. And
they after worshiping him. So the
chapter you quoted that said Jesus is a
prophet says God is his father, that
he's the Christ who was killed, he rose
from the dead the third day, that you're
going to have to believe in his name to
be forgiven, and they worshiped him. So
now do you admit that Luke 24 proves
that Muhammad is an antichrist?
>> Okay, now you won in this. But now the
second question is second question is
that the early disciples of Jesus before
crucifixion they believed that Jesus was
a messiah and the prophet of God.
>> They believed why?
>> Uh they believed that Jesus is prophet
and messiah of God before his
crucifixions.
>> They believed all of that. They believed
he is son of God. He is son of man. He
is prophet. He's priest.
>> Third one is that do you believe? Do you
know about the ark of covenant?
>> What ark of the covenant? Which one?
>> Uh the ark of covenant that contains the
original Torah of Moses.
>> Well, what original Torah? It's the
tablets. The ones that God wrote with
his finger.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Do you believe that the the Torah
tablets in the Ark of Covenant contain
pure truth?
>> They contained what? It contained pure
truth.
>> I don't even know what I can't hear you.
What?
>> Uh uh do you believe that the pills that
the capsules of the uh
>> capsules?
>> Yeah, the capsule uh the the capsules of
Torah in the what do you call it?
>> The capsules of the Torah. You mean the
tablets?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The tablets. Sorry.
>> Yeah. Okay. What about the tablets?
Yeah.
>> The tablets of the Torah in the Ark of
Covenant. Do you believe that they are
the truth?
>> Of course, they're the truth. How do you
know what's in them?
>> Uh I don't know. But do you believe that
if
>> if we find the ark of covenant or the
second coming of Christ uh like the uh
both religion believe and if we find the
ark of covenant then do you believe the
the things that it contains is a pure
truth?
>> It has to be color of truth. It's from
God.
>> Yeah. Okay. So it contains truth.
>> What about it?
>> Uh
uh. Oh my
>> question is because
what's the question?
Oh, okay. He'll be back.
>> Sir,
okay. So
anyway, he'll be back. His mic's not
working. Yeah, I don't know what he's
asking me to talk. So this young man, so
what did you learn again, guys? What did
you learn?
You learned to read verses in context.
You learn
to read verses in context. They quote to
you 19. You read the entirety to show
them. This is the same chapter that says
Christ was killed, was resurrected
physically on the third day. God is his
father. He ascends to heaven. He's
worshiped. and that repentance will be
preached in his name to all the nations.
He's back again. What happened?
>> What happened
>> here? I'm my internet disconnected.
>> So, are you okay now?
>> Yeah, I'm okay.
>> Can you can you open Deuteronomy 18:18?
>> So, wait, you mean Deuteronomy, you
trust it now? It's God's word.
>> Uh, I was talking about the tablets. Uh,
the
>> That's not the tablet. Deuteronomy 18:18
is not the tablet, right?
>> Yeah. So, I do know Deuteronomy 18:18 is
God's word. Uh,
>> no, no. Uh, I will talk about the tablet
later, but uh, can you please open
Deuteronomy 188?
>> One that I've answered five million
times. It can't be Muhammad.
>> No. No. Uh, I'm not trying to prove
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam.
>> I swear I'm not I'm not trying to prove
him. I was just asking you that this
this verse is true or not.
>> Of course, it's true, brother. If it's
in the Bible, it's true. Just get to the
question, man. You know, everything in
the Bible is true. Come on, get to the
question.
>> Uh, I have to check for one minute.
Wait.
>> Huh?
>> Wait. Just wait a second. Just wait a
second.
>> Okay, I'm waiting, brother. I swear I
am. I'm waiting. I'll wait for you. So,
that's okay. Uh do do you know the verse
that is that is about like the if a
prophet makes a prediction uh uh in the
in the word of God and it gets true then
he is a true prophet. I'm not trying to
prove the prophet Muhammad.
>> No it's not. Yeah that's that's
no if a prophet makes a true prophecy
doesn't mean that's a true prophet. It
can be deception. But if a prophet says
something doesn't come to pass. It's a
negative test. It's not a positive test.
It's Proverbs 18:20 to 222. What about
it?
>> Yeah, it says that uh that if a prophet
makes prophecy in the name of God and it
gets true, then he is a true prophet.
I'm not trying to prove prophetam. Is is
this right?
>> No, you mis misinterpreted the prophecy.
It doesn't say that. It says you will
know a false prophet. You will know a
false prophet. when he says something
that doesn't happen, that's proof he's a
false prophet. It doesn't say that if a
prophecy happens, that's proof he's a
true prophet. No, it doesn't say what
you said.
>> Uh uh the verse 22, when a prophet
speaks in the name of Yahweh or God, if
the thing does not come about or come
true,
>> this is the thing which Yahweh has speak
>> exactly what I just said. So when a
prophet says something that turns out to
be a lie, he's a false prophet. But it
doesn't mean that if someone says
something will happen, he's a true
prophet. Because Deuteronomy 13 says
there'll be false prophets who will make
predictions that happen.
>> Okay?
Like this verse is not literal. This
verse is not literally.
>> This verse is not what?
>> Uh this verse is not literal. Like it
says if a prophet makes uh if if a uh
can you scroll down to a verse 22 18:22
>> yes
>> uh when a prophet speaks in the name of
Yahweh if the thing does not come about
or come true that is the thing which
Yahweh has not spoken the prophet has
spoken it uh you shall not be afraid of
him and the next verse I think it says
that if a prophet uh made a prophecy in
the name of Yahweh and it came group
like the brother.
>> It doesn't say that. I just said it
doesn't say that. It says there will be
prophets who will make prophecies that
don't come to pass. So, I just opened
the entire chat to tell you this is the
last verse. You're making things up. I
just showed you that in Deuteronomy 13.
It says that there will be prophets who
will prophesy and it will happen, but
they're going to deceive you because
they're false prophets. So you don't
understand what Dean 18:22 is saying.
It's saying you will know he's a false
prophet. If he tells you this is going
to happen, it doesn't happen. But it
doesn't mean if someone says a prophecy
and happens, he's a true prophet because
then you're going to have to see what he
says about God.
>> Oh
yeah.
>> Here I just told you that. Deuteronomy
13. Here you go. Deuteronomy 13.
So there, this is what they call a
negative test. How do you know that he's
a false prophet because he's going to
make a prophecy doesn't happen. But it
doesn't mean if someone makes a
prediction, he's a true prophet. Now you
guys are learning this, right? Because
God says here, the way you're going to
know whether a prophet is true is by the
message he preaches here. Deuteronomy
13. If a prophet or a dreamer of dreams
arises among you and gives you a sign or
a wonder
gives you a sign or a wonder
and the sign or the wonder comes true.
See notice it will come true. You see
it?
>> Yeah.
>> Which he spoke to you saying, let us
walk after other gods whom you have not
known and let us serve them. You shall
not listen to the words of that prophet
or that dreamer of dreams. For Yahweh
your God is testing you to find out if
you love Yahweh your God with all your
heart, with all your soul.
>> Okay, my net is disconnecting. I'm I'm
staying here. My net is disconnecting.
Just two minutes. Give me two minutes.
>> I'll give you two minutes, guys. Do you
mind if I deal with this young man
before we go into
before we go into Alex Okconor? This
young kid, his salvation's important.
So you guys understand right? You
understand the difference?
Everyone understand the difference.
Let me explain the difference.
You will know a false prophet if he
makes a prediction that fails. That's
the negative test. But the Bible tells
you the opposite isn't true. Please
listen. Learn your faith.
The Bible says the opposite isn't true.
What's the opposite?
Just because someone prophesies the
future and happens doesn't mean he's a
true prophet. Because then you're going
to have to see what his message is.
>> Okay. So, you are going to debate Alex
O' Conor today.
>> No, I'm going to refute his arguments.
He's not going to debate me. He's too
good for me. He doesn't think I'm good
enough. That's why you're debating me
because you think I'm good enough for
you.
>> Yeah, you you are debating since 2000,
man. You are so good.
>> So you admit I'm good enough for you
only, right? But not Alex Okconor.
>> Is David Wood better than you?
>> Yes, he is.
>> Oh my god. I was thinking to debate him.
>> He's better than me. You were thinking
about debating him.
>> Yeah.
>> And you said, "Oh, God." No, he's better
than me. He's he'll he'll destroy you.
>> Okay.
>> Don't debate him.
>> Uh Okay. So I'm saying to you that
debate the orthodox Muslim.
>> Why? Why doesn't he come and debate me
here like you did?
>> Like
>> why doesn't he come?
>> He he will destroy you.
>> Okay, let him come to storm you. Why is
he hiding like Aisha?
>> Uh I don't know.
>> Say hey, why don't you go to his live
stream? If he can answer questions, I'm
not going to be disrespectful to him. So
let him come.
I don't know him personally. So you can
email him like I
>> No, I challenge him to come hundreds of
times. He won't. So if he's not going to
come, I'm not going to any Muslim
platform that I don't do that. No, Siri.
So if you want him to come, all right,
why don't you tell me what his argument
is to see if it's a good argument?
>> If you debate Alexa Connor, uh, who will
win? Like
>> who will win?
>> Yeah. Well, in that case, because he's
debating deity Christ, he will lose. Not
because I'm good, because Jesus is God
and you cannot defeat him.
>> Uh Bart Aman, Dr. Barton,
>> anyone who fights against the truth of
Jesus Christ
and tries to reject
>> like the Jesus like the Jesus said that
the father is greater than I.
>> Okay, good one. You want me to answer
that one? Now you will say that it was
his human form.
>> No, I didn't. You don't know what I'm
going to say. That's not what I'm going
to say.
>> Okay.
>> You want me to show you the answer
first?
>> Yeah.
>> So, we Christians, we don't read a verse
out of context. We read a verse in
context. So, you read 28, but you agree
before you came to 28, there are 27
verses that come before it, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
So first of all, if I want to know what
the father is greater than I means,
there's two ways someone can be greater.
For example, you are greater than your
dog, right?
>> If you have a dog, you don't have a but
your father is greater than you, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now,
does that mean your father is more human
than you? You're less human and you're
inferior.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
So are you less human than your father?
>> Yeah.
>> You are less human. So then what? Are
you half zombie, half human?
>> I am human.
>> But your father is greater than you. So
are you equally human like him?
>> No,
>> you're not. So you're only 90% human.
He's 100% human.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I am equal to him.
So wait, you're equal to him in human
nature?
>> Yeah.
>> And so as a human, your father is not
better than you. He's equal to you and
you have the same worth.
>> Yeah.
>> But he's still greater than you.
>> How's that work? How can he be greater
than you if you're equal to him? H
>> ah. I understanded you.
>> You got it.
>> I understood you.
>> Okay. Before I go on, let me show you
that though the father is greater in
position because Jesus is on earth as a
servant. The same Jesus said earlier in
verse six, John 14:6.
The same Jesus said earlier, Jesus said
to him, I am the way and the truth and
the life. No one comes to the father but
through me. Now according to Islam,
Allah is alhak, the truth and he is the
living, the life. Can a prophet say, "I
am the truth and the life?"
>> No.
>> But Jesus just said it.
>> Okay.
>> And secondly, he says, "God is my
father."
>> H how do I know that the Bible has the
truly words of Jesus?
>> Well, you quoted it, so I don't
understand. You quote, you told me Jesus
said the father is greater than I. So if
you don't know these are the words of
Jesus, why did you quote it?
So I'm confused.
You quoted this saying, "Look what Jesus
said." And then now you're saying, "How
do I know Jesus said it?" So why is it
when a verse sounds like it teaches
Islam, you say, "Jesus said it." But
then when the verse sounds like Islam is
false, how do I know Jesus said it?
Because even the verse you quoted,
notice what you didn't quote.
>> Okay. So can you give me email of Nabil
Kureshi? I have to debate him.
>> Really? Well, I don't have an email to
heaven because Nabil Keshi is in heaven.
Hey, he's dead.
>> Yeah, he went to be with Jesus.
>> Oh, hell no. I didn't knew it.
>> Hell no.
>> He was better than you and David Wood
both.
>> They're both better than me.
>> No. If if we compare Nabil Kuresh and
David Wood together.
>> David Wood taught Nabil.
>> Oh,
>> David. So, I don't know. How can Nabil
be better than David Wood?
>> Okay, so you won this debate. I
>> Okay, now in 28 when it says the father
is greater than I, notice again, God is
the father.
>> What is your age by the way?
>> What is my age? How old do I look?
>> Uh 57.
>> So nice. I'm not a day over 53, but
thank you.
>> You are 53.
>> I'm 53, brother. But you made me old,
man. So nice.
>> Oh my god. Huh?
>> Yeah. So, so I won again. You want to
retire now and I go back to my program?
>> Yeah, you can.
>> God bless you.
Okay.